- Somewhere in there about that.
- How many outlets do you need?
- Uh, just two.
- All right. Charlie ... Charlie Jones.
Charlie, you were the
Warden at, uh, Holman Prison
in Atmore, Alabama?
- Right.
- How many years were
you the Warden at Holman?
- 30 ... oh, well, I was Warden for 18.
I worked in the prison system for 35.
- 35 years. And you grew
up where? In Alabama?
- Right here.
- Tell me about your childhood.
You had both of your parents?
- Yeah.
- How would you describe your childhood?
- Ah, just normal. I went
to school, finished school,
went to college, finished
that, uh, come back here,
built a house,
and uh, I'm nine miles from the prison.
I lived here most of the time.
I've been moved around
all over the state at
different prisons.
- How many prisoners
did you have at Holman?
- Approximately 1,000.
- And you had death row inmates at Holman?
- Right.
- Holman's the only prison
in Alabama that has the ...
- Right.
- ... death penalty ... has executions ...
- Right?
- As the Warden for 18
years, what's your view on
the death penalty? Do you
see it as an effective
way to
control crime
or keep ... keep ...
keep society in line?
- Well, I think you have
to on .. on, uh, bad cases,
uh,
you can't ... you know, certain things,
you can do other things, but
the way death row was set up,
uh,
it's pretty bad. You have
to have a pretty bad crime
to be put on death row.
You had to have a
combination of murder robbery,
murder rape, or something
like that before you
qualify for it.
But,
sooner or later, these other
non-serious crimes,
in my view, have to be done
other ways because the ...
the tax-payers are not
going to pay to have all
of them locked up.
There too many of them.
- It gets expensive. Right?
- Yeah.
- So as Warden at Holman, part
of your job was to perform
the executions. Right?
- Right.
- You were using the electric
chair or lethal injections?
- Is was the chair.
- So by the time a man
gets to the electric chair,
where do you see your role
as the end of his life?
Do you see it as you're
responsible for that?
You're the one that's pulling the trigger?
- Well, technically I guess I was, but
a lot of things happen
between the time that he's
arrested and the time he
has to sit in that chair.
It's a long, drawn-out process
that can last as long as
20 years; sometimes longer than that.
- There's a lot of steps
a suspect would have to
go through before he sits
in the electric chair.
Right?
- Yeah. It ... a crime committed,
and there's an investigation,
and then they follow the
investigation until they
arrest somebody.
And then he's arraigned,
and then he's tried,
and 12 people sit in judgment on him,
and if he's convicted,
he goes to prison ...
goes to death row.
Then his appeal process starts,
and it is long and drawn out.
The Alabama Supreme Court,
Court of Criminal Appeals,
State Court. It can last on and on.
- So by the time he gets
to the electric chair,
it's pretty certain that this
is ... that he is guilty?
- By the time ... yep. Well, not always.
There's some time they can
go right up pretty close
to the time, and the attorney
come up with something
that he appealed one last time to the
Alabama Supreme Court,
and they'll give him a stay.
It don't always last.
It might last a day. It might last a week.
It might last three or four years.
But most of the time,
once I'm served ... or was served
with a warrant ... a death warrant,
then it's getting really serious.
I'd get that warrant 30
days prior to the date,
and during that time, the
attorneys for both sides ...
they get busy,
and they try to come up with
something to stop it.
Sometimes they do.
And
by that time, most times, they didn't.
- What does that death row
inmate's last moments like
before ... before he
is executed?
Can you describe that?
- Well, you're talking about the day-of?
- The day of. Yeah.
- Well, the day of, he's ...
the inmate would spend
most of the day with his
family on the visiting yard.
We'd leave him out there
approximately two hours
before the
time to get him ready.
And we'd take him off the
visiting yard, escort him
back to his cell.
The execution team would get him dressed,
shave his head, shave
his ankle ... left ankle,
and get him ready. By
that time, it's right
around 12 ...
12 a.m.; 12:01 a.m.
And they ...
they would call me. I
would be in my office.
I stayed in my office ...
- 12 a.m. Midnight?
- Do what?
- Midnight?
- Yeah.
I'd stay in my office
while they did that in case
we got a call from the
governor, or from the
Attorney General, or from
the Court, putting it off.
If we didn't, then somebody
would man the phone while I
would go to the death chamber.
By the time I got down
there, they've got him in
the chair,
strapped in, ready to go.
By Law, I had to read
that death warrant to him.
And I would ask him if he
had any last request or ...
... or statement.
Most of them didn't.
If not,
then I would tell the two officers in the
death chamber to make him ready.
Final ... final
readiness was putting the helmet on him
and putting the ankle bracelet on him.
And then, I would leave the death chamber,
and go in next door to the equipment room.
The two officers would come out.
We didn't want to leave
anybody in there with him
for fear that somebody might
pass out and fall into him.
And once they
come out, they'd give me a signal:
Tap on the door.
And
it was all over with.
- It's just a flip of a switch?
- Press of a button.
- Press of a button?
How did this effect you
personally, doing this?
- Well ...
- How many did you perform?
- I did 17 men and one woman.
- How did if effect you personally?
- Well,
that's a good question.
I've never let their problem
become my problem.
And I didn't put them
there. I didn't go out
and arrest them, and
sit in judgment on them.
Once they got there,
that was their problem.
And
they knew that.
And I tried to treat them in
such a way, and my staff
treat them in such a way
that when the time came,
you know, we didn't have
to look away from them. We
could look them in the eye,
and let them know what's
fixing to take place,
and what to watch for, and
you know, "Here it comes."
And afterwards,
you know, it lays on your mind.
It did me.
But not a guilt thing.
Just hoping that I had done everything
to be sure
that his case was as
perfect as it could be,
that there was no way me or
my staff the cause of him
having to sit in that chair
when maybe he shouldn't have.
If he shouldn't have, then
it was somebody else's
mishandling; not us.
So, you know, I ...
I don't lose sleep over it.
To tell you the truth,
I very seldom think about it.
- What kind of reactions
would you see from the
men as they approach their last day?
- Not ... not a lot.
Most of them
was ready.
They would ... you know, we
would take them out of their
regular cell 24 hours ahead
of time and put them in
what we call the Ready
Cell, the Death Cell.
Once we got them down there,
and they were away from all of their
friends on the cell block,
they settled down really well.
I can only recall one
that seemed like he ...
he carried a grudge to the chair,
but the rest of them didn't.
They let it go,
and
most of them, at one time or another,
during that short period,
admitted what they had done.
- Eventually they admitted their crimes?
- Yeah. Yeah.
Not all of them, but most of them.
- Is there one in
particular that stood out
in your memory?
- Yeah. But I can't recall his name.
He ...
you've seen people that
carried a ... I don't
know what you'd call it,
but they were mad all of the time.
You had to be careful
how you spoke to them.
You'd say, "Good morning," to
them, they'd get mad at you.
That's kind of the way this guy was.
- What do you think the core cause is of a
hardened criminal's
behavior? I mean, do you think
it was his environment? Or his family?
Or his brain chemistry?
What do you think is the cause
of what makes a criminal?
- I don't know. If I knew
that, I could probably rest
easy the rest of my life.
I don't know.
I think it's a combination of things.
I think a lot of them
grew up without a father,
not knowing who their father was,
and getting with the wrong
crowd as they grew up,
taking ... making bad choices,
and
going around, trying
to take away stuff that
didn't belong to them.
- It all goes hand-in-hand. Doesn't it?
- Do what?
- It goes hand-in-hand.
- It's ... you know, to
answer your question,
I think it's ... it's just
... it's a combination
of all that stuff.
- You're retired now,
but in your decades of
working in the prison system,
how have you seen criminals change?
I mean, did you see they're more violent?
How are they different now
than they were in the past?
- Uh ...
- Drugs are a bigger part
of the picture now. Right?
- The what?
- Drugs are a bigger part
of the picture now. Correct?
- Oh, yeah. Uh-huh.
Most of ... not on death row,
but regular population ...
most of the inmates in the
regular population that
it maybe didn't come to
prison because of drugs;
but drugs was always involved.
- How do you look at this
part of your life that you ...
that you had? I mean,
this chapter of your life?
It's certainly very unusual.
How do you view it?
- Well, I guess I look at it like
anybody else looks at
something that they do.
A farmer,
or
whatever.
It's something that I did,
and I knew what it was
when I took the the job.
It wasn't no surprise. You know,
I knew that eventually
that I'd have to do that.
And now, you know, I look back on it,
and
I know I did everything I could
to see that they were treated
... not just at death row,
but all of them,
they were treated right, wasn't abused,
and at the same time, now, we didn't ...
we didn't let them us
do us that way either.
But we didn't have that much trouble.
And I look back on that
as that I
did all I could to be sure they ...
they were treated right.
I've met them on the street,
and they would run to me with a hand out;
and you know, some of them I'd recognize,
some of them I didn't. And
they had to tell me who
they were.
I've had some of them tell
me, you know, that I'd
kept them from getting
into bad trouble in prison,
and
I knew by something I
could gauge what I did,
maybe ... maybe I did
all I could to
do what was right.
I don't ... I don't have
any regrets of anything.
And the main thing, I
mentioned it a while ago,
I did not let people
put me on a guilt trip
about what I had to do,
and I did not allow the inmate's problem
to become my problem.
They had to do what they had to do,
I did what I had to do,
and they just have to
let the rough end drag.
- All right, Charlie.
Thank you so much for talking with me.
Very interesting. Thank you.